okay and uh i'll try again
to uh maybe to text him so
okay so we'll go through the documents
that i sent out last night and for
anybody uh
public watching we do have these uh four
documents posted on
the division two webpage at this time um
so i'm gonna let andrea share her screen
uh and we've we'll probably start with
the budget tracking document to start
i'm not sure we're gonna be able to do a
whole lot with it today but i just want
to at least familiarize everybody with
this
um as you know just because we're gonna
update it moving forward each day this
week but at least uh show everyone where
we're starting with monday
today so
this here is kind of breaking up
house bill one for the most part to
start house built two sections in the
middle and then down below just for
everyone's uh
uh understanding i compiled everything
that we've done to this point
so this is what i was referring to at
the end of
last week as far as trying to gather
everybody's proposed
amendments to funding areas house bill
just to kind of put a tracking sheet
together for the division so we can work
off of each day
so i'll run through them very quickly uh
representative heath
um is going to want to discuss
a an amendment adding some positions to
the department of safety
the next one down is we had talked about
as a committee to reduce winter
maintenance
and this would be the amount needed in
dot's budget to balance the highway fund
for the state
the next set um kind of go together
those three
lines for doe relative to school
building we had that discussion with the
department this morning as far as
how much um the top three projects get
and i broke it out just so you can see
depending on
you know which which direction the
committee goes if any
we also talked about fully funding
special education aid
these amounts here represent the current
law three and a half percent
is when it kicks in for the cost of a
student with a
an estimate i worked with the department
to uh project out what those costs may
be
so adding about five and a half million
over the biennium to that line
should fully fund the cad aid or
formerly known a cad a program at doe
and then the next house bill one these
are just nikki mickey hold on just a
second
is that just for three and a half or is
that
for this is just three and a half so
this is the current
law program so if you wanted to change
it to two and a half i think the
department had suggested closer to 10
million dollars a year
in addition an additional 10 million
correct
yeah okay thank you
and then the last straight up house bill
one uh
quote amendment we'll call it at this
point is to flat fund the university
system and community college system
at their um 2011 levels
i also sent and andrew maybe you could
switch over to the hb1 amendment packet
i'm sorry oh yeah
did you say 2011 or 2021 21 i'm sorry if
i said 11 i meant 21. sorry about that
so and so this other document that i
sent you the hb1
amendment packet this is just the detail
behind some of those lines
so for instance that first line that we
had on that summary page there have the
the 3d department of safety positions
lab positions
this is the detail behind it this is
what you'd see actually entered in the
budget in the personnel
salary line they've got positions in
three different areas if you recall when
we went through the department of
safety's budget
so if you want to stay high level that
first document
we'll have that if you want the real
detail behind some of these changes i
did send
a house bill one amendment packet as
well so it's kind of two documents that
work um
that you know one's the more detailed
version of the same stuff
andrea if you want to scroll down this
one you can see kind of what i'm talking
about you'll see the winter maintenance
amendment is the next one
and then further you'll see like the
usnh and ccsnh
so this is when we get into the details
and you start voting on some changes as
we move forward
we'll probably be working off of these
more detailed sheets
just so it's clear what the action is
made by the division
um representative member you can correct
me for a moment i don't think the plan
is to do anything with house bill one
today
that's correct okay so this is really
just in
informational for everyone today i'll
update these sheets again tonight
for tomorrow's work session then again
tuesday night for wednesday so
if there's things you want added if
there's things you decide you want to
withdraw
and you know something that you've put
on here just let me know and i'll update
these sheets
so we can stay focused with our work as
we progress through the week
so back to the budget tracking document
andrea
thank you now there's also going to be
some spending impacts
related to some house bill 2 amendments
and we'll get to the house bill 2
drafting
tracking document here shortly but i'll
just go through a couple of them so the
first one is the dual and concurrent
enrollment
representative heath has an amendment to
appropriate uh one and a half million
dollars per year
for that program with ccsnh
the next uh is relative to the ccsnhusnh
unification plan they said that they
could use a million and a half dollars
estimated for some external support and
the work
that they were going to do for the um
you know proposing some legislation
relative to that plan
we don't have an amendment for that yet
that's still in drafting we're still
kind of working through
any amendment relative to those sections
the um commission to
to recommend an entity to receive police
misconduct complaints
um current in the governor's budget
there was a half a million dollars set
aside
for that entity in fiscal 23
this would be an amendment to
essentially reduce that to a hundred
thousand dollars division one
zeroed out that budget because it was in
the department of administrative
services
this would provide a 100 000 placeholder
so to speak
for whatever that commission proposes
for the next legislative session to
consider
on line 11 representative heath has an
amendment to
provide funding for the irc unhd
innovation
research center this is the funding
level and the current budget 275 a year
we may need to true something up here or
slightly edit it because i believe
division one did put
fifty thousand dollars in there for the
biennium so
um we'll confirm with representative
heath uh what her
if she wants to do 275 per year in
addition to whatever division one does
or just make sure between the divisions
we
set the amount that she'd like uh and
then the last house bill 2 impact that i
have
is mickey before you go on uh
where is that uh funding in the budget
is that in uh division one it is it's
it's a line item in division one's
budget so this would be somewhat
crossing over divisions to do this so
division one has
made their recommendation on how much to
fund the irc
um it's up to representative heath if
she wants to move forward with this or
just rely
on that recommendation that but that's
something we can discuss when
perhaps when she's with us uh for the
next work session
yeah my my concern on that i'm not
opposed to this
amendment but my concern is that um
i don't think that we should do anything
that affects another division's budget
that's my um
[Music]
that's my take on it so anyhow
i'll just leave it at that it relates to
the university system but you're right
in that it
it flows through the department of uh
business and economic affairs budget
which is a division one
responsibility uh
in the last amendment here and this is
still in drafting
uh relative to the public school
infrastructure fund um
there's an amendment to reduce that from
30 million over the biennium down to
essentially one million a half a million
dollars a year
which would free up 29 million dollars
of education
trust fund i should have etf on there
and i'll update that
um for tomorrow's sheet that's not a
general fund situation
uh down below is just a summary of items
we've already approved most of it was
the
there's no general funds here no
education trust funds
these were the kind of those uh budget
technical defect
type amendments that agencies asked for
that we've approved to pass work
sessions
and i've put a total down at the bottom
and i'll track this daily just so
the division knows what we've done to uh
each day
so i don't have anything more to add on
these two documents that we just covered
i just wanted to familiarize everyone
with them so if you have questions or
or anything moving forward hopefully we
understand kind of what i'm trying to
put here for
let me uh let me just make some a couple
comments on
the reduction in the public school
infrastructure fund
um i don't know whether the 500 000 is
the right number
uh this morning they were talking about
um
needing about a million dollars in there
so you know that
that number is uh is pretty fluid
but what i was looking at
um using this money
to fund things like dual and
concurrent enrollment the uh
money for the um uh support for the
study
um the um
the money for no no not that
um addition additional money
for um
boy my my mind is crazy uh
if we decide that we want to uh
reduce the uh the tail
you know that would that would come out
of this
29 million and um
you know it's basically all things that
deal with uh like you know the
increase for um a special ed
uh all of those kinds of things
because i i think that
we have some other shortfalls in the
education trust fund
that are probably
i don't want to say from my perspective
more important than funding
this uh the public school infrastructure
fund
that's just my take on it so um
i wanted to let you know why that
amendment
um went in that we're not you know i'm
not
belittling i guess the uh public school
infrastructure fund
people but i do think that there are
better uses of that money overall so
marjorie i see you have a question i
just i just wanted to also
just interject here that some of that
federal money can indeed be used for
these projects that
people have on the list so that would
seem like a wise
decision to me
thank you uh joe you have a question
yeah thank you madam chair uh could you
uh
what was the original intent of this
fund
i'm working on two computers and trying
to think at the same time
the original purpose of this when it was
formed
was to provide internet connectivity
money for the schools and this occurred
um i want to say it was
after the florida school incident
where there were several children killed
and what the governor wanted to do
was to um provide money to
the schools to improve security
and i think that um caitlin said this
morning
that we had was it 20 million mickey
uh at some point you mean
yeah yeah closer to 30 over the
yeah and they said this morning that all
of that money had been spent
or obligated i guess is the right term
so they did in fact use it for the
purpose
that it was um allocated
and um i sat on that committee
for two years i guess maybe
i don't know some some amount of time
and
um we were very careful in how we
uh allocated it and made sure
that it went to the projects that the
um that were
set in law so
thank you okay
any does it does anyone have any other
questions
okay i don't see any so if we could go
on mickey
sure so um that house bill 2 section
that we just went through with all those
amendments
so if we go to the house bill 2 tracking
sheet now
um those will also be on here so
it's a little bit you know it's that's
kind of the nature of house bill 2
is we have to change house bill 2 but we
also have to reflect any
budgetary impacts you know to the bottom
line we carry it on the surplus
statement
um so anyways you you should remember
this document or something similar to it
last week
i've updated it with the decisions that
we've made to this point so some of the
sections in house bill 2 assigned to us
we've already taken care of so if we
jump down to
house bill 2 page 22 section 44 we
accepted that
as it's in the governor's recommended
budget no change
the next section would be relative to
education funding i think at that point
that this is probably on hold
um i don't think we have no amendments
relative to these sections
uh for the division's consideration
from the conversation this morning i
think there's still some uh
discussions to be had on education
funding
um oh yes along along along with
representatives lin's
uh nuclear attack that he provided
that's very true uh the
the next section is kind of that
technical section relative to the
tobacco settlement funds and if you
recall we amended it to
open up the uses of the education trust
fund to line up with what we're actually
spending
in the budget so we adopted amendment
zero six nine three h at a previous um
work session uh public school
infrastructure would be the next set of
sections in um
house bill 2. there is an amendment
that's relative that includes that 14
and a half million dollar reduction per
year that we just discussed
um that amendment as of the time that i
put this together
was still in drafting i have received it
from os and i just needed to review it
so when i
update this for tomorrow and send
everyone their documents um
we'll have an amendment for for those
sections
the crisis intervention team training
and the the
bears we'll call just the bears sections
we dealt with those um
at a previous work session
the next uh set of sections is relative
to ccs and h and usnh
um there is an amendment in drafting
that represent turcotte's been working
on
we do not have that but we will have
that for tomorrow we
so i believe the plan is to have a work
session relative to those sections
uh tomorrow at 10. uh correct me if i'm
wrong representative omburger
no that's correct okay um
the next section page 61 section 133 so
we have an amendment for this and i
think this is one that we could probably
deal with today if the division wanted
to so if you recall
um this is um relative to the department
of transportation's ability to
seek reimbursement or liability for
damage done to highway or fixtures or
um you know roadways
so one thing that the judiciary
committee had concerns with
was that in house bill 2 there's a
section that allows for this
law to be applied retrospectively
so if you go to the house bill 2
amendments andrea
uh representative umberger has an
amendment here zero nine zero eight nine
five h that would essentially just
delete that section um
paragraph three relative to that law
being retrospective
that's really all i have to say on on
that that's kind of where we're at
it was that very first one uh andrew
page one
is there anyone that has a
okay seeing none represent lynn would
you call the roll please
yes and so this is this is uh voting to
approve
amendment 2021-08958
is that correct that's correct all right
let me just i just want to make a note
adam's chair do you need a motion for
that
uh yeah uh yeah oh i guess we do thank
you joe
do i have do i have a second i'll second
thank you thanks for keeping me straight
not a problem all right um
all right so the motion is made by
representative umberger seconded by
representative lynn
um and i'll call the roll uh
yeah all right um
uh we're over here okay uh
representative petry
petri voces uh representative lynn votes
yes
uh representative porter representative
porter votes yes uh
representative ellison yes
uh representative murray very votes yes
uh and representative humber
oh what's up sorry i reckon turquoise is
here representative turca
sorry for the delay i was in our weekly
meeting uh i'll
vote yes all right and representative
umber
representative humber votes yes all
right the vote is 7-0
thank you so uh well we got one thing
done
uh mickey what's next so the next
section is on page 61 of your house bill
twos and i believe everyone
i know we've got uh representative
ellison and uh
well i think representative allison's
our new sub for today
um i think i sent you a house bill 2
link so i hope you're able to
understand where we are with this do you
have any questions representative i i
don't thank you very much
okay so the next section is uh sections
135 and 136
and this was relative to federally
funded um real estate that dot sells
just making it clear where the the
disposition of revenue relative to those
parcels goes
um i believe the uh public works and
highways committee chimed in on this and
was good with it
and there's no house bill one impact to
this so
i think the committee could move on with
this if there's no other
concerns is there anyone that has a
seeing none could i have a motion please
what was the amendment number again uh
there's actually no amendment number for
this one we'll just be accepting it as
it is in house bill 2.
okay thank you i'm sorry do you have a
like a shorthand title for how i should
raise this acceptance
i think this is acceptance of disposal
of federal funds
it could just be accept section 135 and
136.
oh okay great
[Music]
go ahead and call the roll all right so
i'm sorry motion moved by petrie uh
seconded by
we don't we don't we don't need a motion
on this
oh we don't worry all we're doing is
accepting
what was put forth by the governor okay
all right uh representative petry
vichy votes yes uh representative lin
votes yes representative porter
representative porter votes yes
representative ellison representative
allison bauchias
representative murray very votes yes
representative turca turcotte chess
and representative umber representative
hamburger votes yes
okay thank you um mickey the next one
uh okay similarly uh sections 137 to 139
uh do not have a direct state fund
impact in the budget
uh and these sections were also cleared
with
the chair of the transportation
committee i believe and they
reviewed it and did not have any
concerns with with these clarifications
is there anyone that has a problem
representative porter go ahead i don't
have a problem i'm just curious
why this wasn't um done in a
piece of legislation is there any
rationale for that if it's just
definitions yeah i i think that what
happened
is that um d.o.t gave this to the
governor as something that needed to be
updated
and um and so he did
but um it
it is you know i can't answer why there
wasn't any legislation on it
oftentimes there are things that uh
fall into hb2 that have not gone through
the um you know things like this so
that's all i can say i don't know
sometimes too representative it's a
timing thing so
legislative filing may pass but the
the governor's budget doesn't come out
till the second week of
uh february so sometimes agencies will
seek to see if the governor will support
putting something
into the trailer bill it's just that i
remember seem to be remembering
long debates on the floor having to do
with unmanned
spacecraft or aircraft before and i was
i think all this is is just a
a definition update
that that would affect you know like
i know we've had discussions on the
floor about unmanned aircraft spying on
you
and doing all that stuff none of that is
okay representative lynn seeing nothing
nobody's saying no
let us vote to accept
all right thank you uh representative
petrie
representative petri vocias uh
representative lynn votes yes
representative porter porter votes yes
representative ellison representative
allison votes yes
representative murray murray votes yes
representative turca representative
turkoff beautiful
and representative umber representative
umberger votes yes
all right it's a vote of seven to zero
okay mickey if you would continue please
sure the next sections
are uh sections 140 and 141
which are relative to a an appropriation
a general fund appropriation from a few
years back
that still has remaining unspent dollars
that the governor's budget
recommended uh lapsing those dollars
into the highway fund as a way of
helping balance the highway fund budget
for the next two years
so this is 8.1 million dollars
that is essentially treated as addition
or income to the highway fund as
we're balancing it for the next two
years so without this section
you'd essentially create an 8.1 million
is there anyone that has a problem
seeing none where
we will vote to accept sections 140
through 141
and representative lin if you would call
the role please
certainly uh representative petry
representative petrie votes yes
representative lynn votes yes
representative porter
order votes yes representative ellison
uh ellison votes yes representative
murray
hurry votes yes representative turca
turcotte voces and representative
homberger
representative umberger voces all right
again it's a vote of seven to zero in
thank you very much um mickey if you'd
like to
continue please sure section 144
is relative to the department of
safety's authorized transfers
um in house bill 2 currently and the
previous house bill 2.
i believe you have a question
representative sorry i don't know
go ahead represent porter it was just a
silly comment
madam chair i was going to say if we
keep this up they might accuse us
of being bipartisan in this division
keep up with all these 7-0 votes but
i'll put my hand down now and be quiet
that's that's the way it should be
okay we can all
we can all take credit for being
bipartisan how's that
okay mickey go ahead uh so
this section is relative to department
of safety's authorized transfers
currently
under the current budget and in house
bill 2 is recommended out of the
governor
it allows the department with the
department of administrative services
budget office approval
to move some money within some class
lines that are otherwise restricted by
law
there's no budget impact to that it just
provides the department some flexibility
and moving money around
this amendment adds on to this and if
you recall there was a discussion when
we had the department with us
to grant them authority for the biennium
only to move money around
to fill positions that are currently
unfunded
so for instance if they have a funded
because position and
budgets excuse me positions in the
budget have money tied to them
so for instance if they have a program
specialist two that's funded
and a program specialist four that's not
funded
they could move money between those
positions and fill the one that they
would like to hire for
there's at least two other agencies that
have this authority
in house bill 2 now i believe oi
department of information technology and
corrections if i'm not mistaken so this
was something that the department had
asked for thank you andrea
and there's really no direct budget
impact to this it just provides
okay uh this is the
the amendments to hb2 it's the second
one
correct amendment zero six eight six h
yeah the second page on that the
so this was uh we had discussed this and
i
think that basically we were all in
[Music]
in agreement so um
is there anyone that objects to us
voting on this today
okay seeing none could i have a motion
to accept amendment zero
six eight six please per cop makes
a motion to accept uh zero six
eight six h as a man
representative lin would you call the
role please
uh representative uh petry
representative peter votes yes
uh representative lynn votes yes
representative porter
quota votes yes representative ellison
ellison votes yes representative murray
murray votes yes representative turca
uh representative turcotte votes yes and
representative umberger representative
hamburger votes yes
all right so again vote of 7 to 0 in the
affirmative
thank you very much mickey would you
continue
sure the next amendment that we have is
0 9
2 1 h which is part of the um
i think the word we've been using is
entanglement between the dashboard
camera fund and the commission to
provide recommendations to study an
entity relative to law enforcement
misconduct
so we're going to carve these two
programs out separately into two
different amendments
the first is uh zero nine two one provo
proposed by representative heath
that essentially
does what the underlying house bill 2
does however it does allow for the
department of safety
to fund a position from this
million-dollar appropriation for the
dashboard camera fund
so if you look on lines 14 through 16
you see where that it provides
permission for the department to utilize
the fund
to pay for a business administrator
position which the department had
nikki do you know if this is the lesser
of the two
cost because safety did tell us they
could
use a lower cost
i don't i don't know that answer i can
check in with steve
um at the department if you'd like but
this when i asked him for the details of
the position they want this is
what he had given me uh was the business
administrator one position okay well i
guess they can make a different decision
right
um the way it's written now
i mean that the the bill this amendment
is pretty specific to a
business administrator one position but
it's their
it's the one they selected so if they
wanted to change their mind later and do
a lesser position or a greater position
as far as labor grade
they wouldn't be able to without
reclassifying that position through
personnel
um i i
yeah i i think we better check on that
before we
uh proceed to a vote just to make sure
that we've got the right
the right position i actually have steve
in the attendees now i could oh okay
yeah put him right on the spot and pull
him right in
mr lavoy are you there i am here
okay yes mickey has a question for you
steve the business administrator one
position is this uh
can you provide us some context of this
versus any other
option for personnel to administer this
program
uh yes so we had we were originally
requesting a program specialist three
position which is a higher labor grade
um went back and and talked with our
grants team
and um we were able to reduce that
position down to a business
administrator one uh which is a
lower labor grade that's a labor grade
um and so uh there there is some cost
savings by going with this
classification
as opposed to the original that we had
mickey this authorizes this position to
come out of the
um the money that we've allocated
is and then the rest of it just um
straightens out and takes out all that
other stuff
and we'll have a different amendment to
add that back
correct this this amendment here is just
specific to the dashboard camera fund
the body cam
fund and the the other commission on the
uh
police misconduct will handle in a
different amendment
okay is there anyone that has a problem
okay all right representative lin when
you're ready would you call the roll
please
yes and what what is uh it's amendment
09218h
correct all right thank you uh
representative petry
representative petri votes yes
representative lin votes yes
representative porter porter votes yes
representative ellison ellison votes yes
representative
all right vote of seven to oh in the
affirmative
the next amendment is uh
0922h which is relative to the
commission to
recommend the entity to receive the law
enforcement
misconduct complaints so on um
it's on page five of the amendment
packet starting with section 148 and
this is where when we string house bill
2 these sections will still be near each
other but
they will be separate and distinct so
the only changes here between
what was proposed by the governor and
this and the amendment is
if you go down to lines uh 15 through 17
the director of the police standards and
training council and the commissioner of
safety or their designees
would be appointed to this commission
and that was something that was
discussed in division
and that's what this rec this amendment
does
and then continuing down
um scroll down for me andrew thank you
there is an appropriation here of 100
in the fiscal year 23 to essentially be
a set aside
to provide funding for whatever the
entity is that this commission comes up
with
in the governor's recommended budget
there was um
over half a million dollars set aside
for this purpose in the administrative
services budget
division one will be taking all that
money away just blowing blowing that
budget away
this amendment here would put 100 000
aside
uh for this entity uh if you scroll down
section 150 on line five there there is
a contingency
with that appropriation so in the event
that
this commission you know the work that
the commission recommends
puts in a bill next session if an entity
is never established for whatever reason
uh this appropriation of a hundred
thousand dollars essentially just stays
in the general fund
it wouldn't be made if there was no
purpose for doing so so
um other than that that's that's all the
is there anyone that has a problem
uh representative lynn you know what the
only i don't really have a problem with
voting on it the only question i had is
wasn't um didn't we when we had the
discussion
um wasn't there wasn't there some
question about
um should we change the provision the
provision that talks about the four
other members um doesn't
it doesn't provide how they get
appointed and i thought we
that there was some discussion about uh
wanting to change
that to say how those four people get
appointed
i think it's up it's up in the earlier
part um line 18
uh yes right yeah so so this
this amendment doesn't change that so
it's still
i guess subject to interpretation and
probably assume that it would be the
leact commission itself who who
determines the members that would sit on
this commission
um i mean if
if the committee wanted to work on this
and do something different i can
amend i can change this and come back
with a different amendment or
it's it's really up to the division you
know i just raised the i mean it's not
it's it's certainly not a deal breaker
from my perspective but i just wanted to
raise the issue if anybody else thinks
i don't think that's necessary because
um this is a outgrowth
of the leak committee and
i am sure that this group will report
back to the leak committee uh before any
legislation
is uh submitted so
i think i don't i don't really think
it's necessary
okay does anyone have a problem with
seeing none i will uh ask
for abortion to approve amendment
thank you representative lin would you
call the role please
yes certainly um uh representative petry
representative petrie votes yes
representative lynn votes yes
representative porter reporter votes yes
representative allison ellison votes yes
representative murray murray votes yes
representative turcotte terracotta
and representative umber umberger votes
yes
all right uh vote of 7-0 in the affirm
thank you so let's go on mickey if we
could
uh the next one is the the final uh
section
that i think we can consider just
accepting as it is in house bill 2.
so this was section 149 on page 65
relative to establishing the
uh radio infrastructure procurement
standards
with department of safety and with admin
services
uh we heard from the department as to
the necessity of this and there's no
real uh you know line to point to in the
budget that
that's relative to this section um
and there's no amendment so it's an up
or down at this point
are there um is there anyone
that has a problem if we vote on this
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept
the department of safety
radio infrastructure equipment purchases
i guess we didn't need that we just
needed to say accept excuse me
okay representative lynn would you call
the role
please yes certainly uh representative
featuring
uh representative lynn votes yes
representative porter
representative hamburger votes yes all
right
okay um the state
scholarship program we decided to
eliminate that right mickey
correct so we do have an amendment
amendment 0
9 0 7 h which
um essentially eliminates all of those
changes to the state
but adds one new provision
and does a little bit of statutory
housekeeping
so the new provision here andrea's
highlighted
basically would allow for the college
tuition
savings plan advisory commission who
currently oversees
the higher education endowment trust
fund the unique dollars as well as the
governor's scholarship program
this would allow them to decide if they
feel they would like to transfer money
between those two funds for the per
for the programs they administer there'd
be no
legislative required approval with this
it would essentially just allow
that commission to manage the funds
between the dollars between those two
funds as they see fit
the next provision and it's really the
remainder of the bill
it was kind of observed that the
governor's scholarship program
and the fund still resided in the
so um this um
[Music]
this amendment here just lifts the
entire program right from that chapter
and puts it
over with the uh the higher education
scholarship
section of law so everything after here
there are no changes it is literally a
cut and paste
just to reorganize the statute a little
bit more
in line with the current administration
representative porter thank you
uh madam chair mickey can you just
repeat what you just said about this
last section it just
moves it from what to what so currently
it's
the governor's scholarship for and when
it was established it was under the
governor's office's
office of strategic initiatives okay
last budget
it was moved to be under the
administration of the higher education
scholarship commission
but it never got moved in rsa this
amendment just
moves it out of rsa to kind of a more
appropriate place
as far as who's truly administering that
program so it is a
you know statutory housekeeping so to
speak thank you
and can i have one more question madam
chair certainly we can have all the
questions we need
okay um i know there was some concern
the other day and we talked about this
of the possibility of one fund draining
completely another fund if this was
allowed
but i think we settled that with that it
wouldn't happen but i would like once
again to just be assured
that by doing this change we're not
going to have the
unique funds all end up in the
governor's funds or vice versa
this this amendment would authorize all
those decisions to be made by the
higher education endowment uh
scholarship advisory commission i
probably just butchered the name of it
but there it would be up to them to
decide how much money for each program
so
um if they voted to do what you're
suggesting
this would be this would give them the
permission to do so i guess so
there's nothing limiting that from
happening
yeah thank you um is i guess you know
that was a big concern of mine
uh that that you know one gets dumped
into the other um
can you tell me what that would mean and
is there you know should we consider a
way to prevent that from happening
and my other question is what are the
sections that get eliminated i think it
starts on page
or it's on page 70 it's 162
until where what's the end for that part
thank you
these sections 160 through 168 that get
overwritten by the amendment
that's it 162 to 168 160
oh the whole thing yeah yeah gets
replaced by
this amendment the amendment okay thank
you and can you speak to uh you know
i worry about you know something
nefarious about taking all the money
from one to the other
i'll defer to representative umberger to
speak more on this idea but i
think it's in the uh context of at this
time division one has recommended
not appropriating any additional funds
for the governor's scholarship program
and this amendment would at least give
flexibility to that
commission should they want to allocate
any of their current funding source to
the other program
but i'll defer to representative
umberger to speak further
nope that's that's exactly right mickey
and there is currently money in the
governor's scholarship program
that has not been spent and
um i mean if
you know i i personally trust this
commission
to do the right thing and to make sure
that uh
the money is dispersed because even
though
um
[Music]
both both scholarship things are really
pretty much the same
they're not there's not a big difference
between what
unique does and what the governor's
scholarship does it was
primarily the the governor wanted at the
time
to show that he cared about the cost of
education
so that's my that's my take on it
representative lynn yes
just the only question i had uh madam
chairs am i understanding correctly
mickey that this change that we're
talking about voting on now
does does not have anything doesn't i
well i shouldn't say it doesn't have
anything to do with
but this does not we're not a by
approving this
we're not approving the the uh
proposal to uh for the loan forgiveness
is that correct yeah what this is what
this amendment is effectively doing is
eliminating that proposal
so this is this is overwriting
everything the governor recommended in
these sections
with only what you see in this amendment
so it's effectively a
a delete and an ad but just kind of done
in one action
so that's the student loan debt relief
program
administered with the bfa that would be
out of the
recommendation from division two with
this amendment
okay representative thank you
uh let me just respond to represent lynn
a second
what is that called sllr is that the
the program where they're giving money
to nurses
the student loan repayment yeah student
loan repayment program or something it's
called
yeah uh and there's as i understand it
there's still money in there
and so that would continue
that workforce initiative would continue
uh this doesn't do anything to change
that
but this just says that we're not going
to
and i guess there's probably money left
in um
the dollars that were initially put out
for
um regenerative
whatever regenerative uh stuff
yeah so so the proposal to direct some
of the unique
dollars to that program all that would
come out that would not be
that would be replaced with this
amendment but from a previous program
i understand there's also some dollars
i'm not familiar with with that other
program enough to know i think that's
something that's
tied to division three and i think it's
something they look at but
well i think it was in division one
there may be one okay
okay um because it
uh i don't know which anyhow
uh representative porter
thank you madam chair and i i admit that
i don't understand completely how this
is at 729 is that the number that you
use
to discuss this but there's an endowment
and then there's money for scholarships
so this wouldn't change anything to have
having to do with the endowment just the
money for scholarships
that in that portion of the unique
scholarship
program is that right the higher
education
commission or whatever they're called uh
voted last year
to change the percentage that goes to
scholarships
and the percentage that goes to
endowment right it used to be
80 20 endowment to scholarships
now it is 70 to scholarships
thank you representative murray
thank you we can go back to slurp for a
minute um
where is that program and is that
program still funded
all i know is it still has money but
where it is i have no clue
where does the money come from i believe
the legislature
uh put money in the program when
uh when we were you know i mean not that
it's changed any
but we're having a lot of trouble with
uh
hiring nurses and so this was sort of
like an incentive
but where is it i have no clue yeah
so do we want to vote on this or
represent lynn did you have a another
comment
um you know i i guess i'm i mean i
if the consensus is to vote on this i
can i can vote on it
um and probably support it i'm uh
i i i guess i'm not i'm not completely
sure that i'm
although i although i think that that
you know doing what we're doing here is
probably the right thing um
i'm not completely sure that that uh
you know the what the governor proposed
there with the student loan forgiveness
is
is a bad idea um but if every
i guess what i would say is i'm not so
committed to the other to the position
that it is uh
uh that it is a good idea that if
everybody else on this
uh committee thinks that we should vote
to do
what the what the amendment proposes i'm
i'm so moved oh thank you
i'll second
senator lynn would you call the role
please yes i'm sorry and was that
representative porter the second
yes it was thank you
yes um representative featuring
president petrie votes yes
representative lynn votes yes
representative porter porter votes yes
representative ellison votes yes
representative murray murray votes yes
representative turcotte turacotvocias
representative umberger representative
umberger votes yes
the vote of seven to zero in the firm
and let me let me just say that if um
you know the senate feels strongly about
uh
paying off student loans they can
put something back in so that's
you know we're we're not the last bite
of the apple so to speak
okay um let's go on mickey we're making
some progress here
sure so the next amendment now we're
getting into new sections so these would
not be amendments that replace anything
in house bill 2. those would just be
brand new sections to the bill
the first one is amendment 0852h
proposed by representative umberger that
would essentially lift administration of
the dual and concurrent enrollment
program from the department of education
and just put everything with the
community college system of new
hampshire
so this amendment makes no dollar
changes in any way
it just rather than the money being
appropriated and flowing from
doe to ccsnh the program would just be
administered entirely by ccsnh
we we really haven't discussed this one
before so i would
ask that you uh take a look at it
um and uh
if you remember um
doe had zeroed out this line
and uh said that they didn't think they
should
um
[Music]
be the administrator of it we reached
out to the community college
and they said they had no problem and
they provided some
language for us and um
[Music]
hopefully we'll be able to put some
money into
this program so um
but i think we i think we need to uh
to think about this a little bit more
than
although i guess mickey we could in fact
approve this switch without any money
assigned to it correct correct so we
have two separate house bill two
amendments
right now one that does what we
discussed just
lifting the administration and then the
next amendment from representative heath
would appropriate
a million and a half dollars a year for
this program so they are two separate
uh decisions for the committee
representative porter
thank you madam chair um i think it does
make sense to do this if
doe doesn't want it um but i
we can do this in two separate
amendments we don't need to have it all
in one
so if we if we worked on this today we
could work on the other one tomorrow
senator murray thank you in the second
amendment
when it says that you know the 1.5
million for funding the dual
um does funding include you know money
for the students but also for the
administration of the program
uh when i when that one came in i don't
know if we were clear that it was also
that's a good question i mean there's
nothing in here
either prohibiting or allowing for
administration
i do not believe i'd have to double
check i'm not i don't think the
department
cuts any admin i don't actually speak
uh i'm not sure of that so if you want
to
craft this appropriation to be specific
to allow for
uh administrative costs to be deducted
or that it'd be a hundred percent for
uh you know paying for the courses i
think we could maybe
um tweak the amendment to do whatever
you desire on that
it seems they might require some
administrative support so they might
like that flexibility
similar to what we did with department
of safety and
uh you know the administration for the
body cam for the municipalities
okay so um
do we want to vote on moving the program
from doe
to community college today or do we want
to wait on that
for me i'm okay making the move but i'd
like to check with heath
about if we need to have language for
administration i will
offense we won't we won't do this we
won't do this one here
we'll just do the other one all right
don't move madam chair second
thank you did you get that
representative lynn
i did yes um all right so moved by
petrie seconded by lynn
representative petrie peter revotes yes
representative lynn votes yes
representative porter
yes representative ellison yes
representative murray murray votes yes
representative turcotte representative
votes yes
and representative representative
umberger votes yes
it's a vote of 7-0 in the affirmative
thank you so mickey we're on a roll you
got something else for us
yeah so we'll skip over zero eight nine
three h and um
we can decide whether that amendment
should be modified uh for another work
session
so the next amendment would be one that
representative
weiler asked to be drafted and for
division two to consider relative to
school planning committee vacancies and
that's zero seven eight two h
i am not your subject matter expert when
it comes to local
school boards or cooperative school
boards
i can point you to the changes proposed
on line 14 on the amendment and then
uh 27 are the two changes just
i'll let the committee read through
those and i i can't really answer a
whole lot for you here
uh representative porter
thank you madam chair um sitting as i
have for many years on the municipal and
county government committee
i really need to read over this this is
a change that i want to know more about
so
um and get some opinions on to be honest
um
it sounds like something that should
have a hearing
and i i don't feel comfortable um
voting on it without some public input
as i understand it
um this was
in hb2
two years ago and
with all of the stuff that happened
during during that budget cycle
um this amendment uh somehow or other
got dropped out
and this is dealing with um
cooperative area
school districts and uh so yes i have
i have no problem uh you know just kind
of
passing over this but i would ask that
uh the folks that are going to be here
tomorrow
are not tomorrow wednesday that we um
we take a good look at this and um
i will talk to uh representative
wyler and see if he can uh
be on the call for a few minutes to
describe this amendment
representative you have a uh yeah i was
going to echo uh
what representative uh
porter said um i would like to know a
little bit more
and and maybe just an example of what
they're trying to do
uh because i i too do not understand i i
don't understand
uh any of this so that would be helpful
thank you
okay so we will uh mickey
you're not supposed to be picking out
the tough ones okay
let's i will uh
i'll speak to representative wyler and
uh
what's next so the next one we briefly
touched on it before the
representative heath's amendment to fund
the irc the innovation research center
so we probably want to skip that one for
now
for a day when we get into the you know
the money uh
decisions i agree the next amendment
zero eight four five h
we've discussed this at a previous work
session relative to the department of
transportation
if lapse estimates are met at the end of
this year
amounts that they lapse above their
portion of the laps they get to keep to
buy equipment
that's amendment zero eight four five h
i'd like
to uh hold off on this one please okay
the last two amendments that i have for
us today are relative to
retained bills that we've got in
division two
the first this is actually going back to
the first public hearing we had i think
back in february
on the charter school lease aid cap
currently it's a 30 000
per school per year cap i believe this
amendment lifts it to
50 uh in in accordance with house bill
521 that passed the house and was
referred to finance
this bill does not result in
any impact to state spending
it just allows for
the cap to be up to 50 for a
reimbursement there's 500 000
a year for this program in the budget
and it is pro-rated
depending on the appropriation available
so
in all likelihood 500 000 will be spent
to this
program each year if this bill here this
amendment rather
just kind of reallocates how much can go
to each school when the when the
uh do we want to uh do something with
this today or would you
i guess i would prefer to wait okay no
okay um go ahead mickey
the last amendment is amendment number
zero nine one h eight which is relative
to
a section that's in house bill 594 that
we had a work session on i believe last
week
um relative to school building a this
doesn't take
all of the bill and put it into house
bill 2. to
it carves out the 10-year plan that was
discussed if you recall
so rather than that portion you know
staying in the retain bill to be worked
on
later this would at least move this
policy of the house forward
if you recall this bill has already gone
to education
and passed the full house and was
anyone have any thoughts on this
so there's not a money amount tied to
this this is just
um basically including the policy that
came out of education
correct yeah this bill also had the
changing the 50 million dollar cap on
school building aid to a floor
that would have had a cost to it this
section is just the non-direct budget
impact for
the development of the 10-year plan for
school building aid projects
other comments is there anyone that has
uh representative ellison i i don't have
a problem at all but i i would just
reinforce that it went through education
and there was no uh there are no issues
there
and we need a we need a 10-year plan for
okay i obviously i don't disagree with
that
so could i have a motion
motion to approve amendment zero nine
one eight
seeing none representative lynn when
you're ready you can call the role
uh thank you representative petry
presenter peter of ocs
representative lynn votes yes
representative porter
quarter votes yes representative ellison
ellison votes yes representative murray
marie votes yes representative turcotte
uh turcotte votes yes and representative
umberger
representative umberger votes yes all
right
7-0 vote in the affirmative
thank you all very much so what's next
mickey
that's all i've got for us today and i
feel like we uh
okay uh does anyone
have anything else that we need to
can i can i just ask a matter of uh
chair uh
i i assume since i from that that i
hadn't heard from you that you did find
somebody to
to substitute for me uh tomorrow or not
um i don't have a name right now but
uh i should have somebody
all right thank you and i'm sorry for
this uh
things got pretty screwed up i'll tell
you but anyway
oh i will uh i will make sure that we
have a
uh a sub for you tomorrow
right and wednesday right yeah
yeah great thank you yeah okay and
uh representative murray
um i understand representative lay
is that was ice falling off my house
um sorry representative lay
is going to be in tomorrow that's my
understanding
okay and i guess that's substituting
again
for um or for representative porter we
can't be here tomorrow
but that's wednesday not tomorrow i
can't be here wednesday
so are you here tomorrow i'm here
tomorrow tomorrow's monday
today is monday right yeah
okay i can't be here wednesday but i
will be here tomorrow
so i than i think mary's here tomorrow
too so i think think
we're all here wednesday is the next sub
day
oh okay fine that's thank you
i can't i can't keep track of me much
less seven other people so
i appear to be the same way so we need
your card yeah so
so to make the confusion worse for us we
haven't been able to keep track of days
we got a calendar for this year and we
got it through
the internet when we found out it was in
the european calendar and the week
started on monday
so we were looking at this calendar we
were always off by a day because
we were we were looking at the european
week so
i understand
okay representative ellison you have a
question mr
uh comment thank you madam chair and
thank you for including me in this
meeting
uh i've enjoyed this work with all of
you
well thank you so uh
10 o'clock tomorrow morning it's been a
pleasure working with
uh everyone today and um
so we're we're doing very well
um i know that we have uh
chosen to hold off on some of the more
uh
content contentious issues but
we'll get through this okay all of us
together so we'll uh
we'll keep smiling and i'll see everyone
at
well no i won't i'll see whoever's here
tomorrow morning
at ten o'clock okay please take care and
have a
you